[Music]  I'm dr. Steven s Morris professor of  epidemiology at Columbia University  Mailman School of Public Health in New  York this pandemic virus is the third in  the series of new corona viruses  introduced into the human population in  the first three decades of the 21st  century and one of many merging viruses  I'll discuss how these viruses emerge  and how we could have seen it coming and  been better prepared to stop it earlier  there's also been a lot of  misinformation what some people call  info demmick about these infections  fortunately lab routes platform provides  a great way to give needed attention to  the best scientific knowledge during  this pandemic  [Music]